eine Umarmung und ein Händedruck reichen
nicht Olaf Scholz bekommt in Paris noch
kurz den Rücken gestreichelt und noch
einen Händedruck und noch einen so viele
um wie der beste Freund von Frankreichs
Präsident auszusehen vielleicht ist er
es ja auch wieder es ist nicht gut für
Deutschland und für Europa wenn
Deutschland sich isoliert als macron
Scholz im Oktober diesen Satz nach
schleudert war von Panzern noch nicht
die Rede aber da fing es an das
Rätselraten über Scholz
es geht eben nicht nur um die heute
diskutierten militärischen
Angelegenheiten schon beim Streit um die
Subventionen für Energie hat Deutschland
einen Alleingang gemacht
[Musik]
seit die Ukraine um Leopard 2 Panzer
bittet rätselt halb Europa über Scholz
und seine SPD noch nie haben so viele
Länder so verzweifelt auf ein Jahr oder
nein aus Berlin gewartet
Großbritannien drängt alles hänge an
Deutschland ob Deutschland nun selbst
Leopard 2 liefert oder ob es anderen die
Lieferung erlaubt ich fordere meine
deutschen Kollegen auf es zu tun
drängt wir appellieren an die deutsche
Politik wir appellieren an die deutsche
Öffentlichkeit an Bundeskanzler Scholz
Verantwortung zu übernehmen
wir brauchen euch jetzt
Litauen braucht euch die Ukraine braucht
euch wir brauchen deutsche Führung
deutsche Führung so selbstbewusst wie
kaum ein Kanzler vor ihm hat Olaf Scholz
der EU nicht nur Führung versprochen
sondern führen das könne nur heißen
zusammenführen aber in dieser Woche wird
Scholz der zusammenführer so scharf wie
nie als auseinanderkanzler kritisiert
vom EU-Parlament wo es als
außergewöhnlich gilt dass ein
Regierungschef Namen endlich gerügt wird
Olaf Scholz soll führen soll die
Panzerlieferungen europaweit initiieren
und koordinieren eingebracht von den
Grünen unterstützt von der FDP die
Parteien die mit Scholz regieren sind
die die ihn am wahrnehmbarsten
kritisieren
ich glaube wenn Sie sich hier im
Europäischen Parlament umhören dann
werden sie sehr sehr kritische Töne
gegenüber Deutschland hören und wir
wollen nicht einfach nur Kritik
verstärken sondern wir wollen Kritik
konstruktiv wenden also europäischen
Partner sehen ehrlicherweise dass das
deutsche zögern von Scholz und den
Sozialdemokraten kommt in Berlin und
Brüssel sind es ja wir Liberale und die
Grünen die vor allen Dingen für
gemeinsame Waffenlieferungen mehr Druck
machen das deutsche zögern den Vorwurf
den Verbündete Parteien und Verbündete
Länder erheben Scholz und seine SPD
finden ihn hoch ungerecht als die
FDP-Politikerin streckt Zimmermann
kritisiert Deutschland habe leider
gerade versagt unterstellt ihr
SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht sie wolle
als nächstes nach Flugzeugen oder
Truppen schreien kein EU-Land
unterstütze die Ukraine so sehr wie
Deutschland von grenzschutzfahrzeugen
und Minenräumen Geräten über
hunderttausend Erste Hilfe Kids und
aufklärungsdrohnen bis hin zu
Nutzfahrzeugen und brückenlegepanzern
der deutsche Kanzler sei sehr
entschieden aber auch immer
besonnen er ist besonnen dass er
besonnenheits pflegt Besonnenheit im
Handel aber eben auch mit Besonnenheit
ich weiß dass die von mir geführte
Bundesregierung eine Unterstützung der
großen Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger für ihr Vorgehen hat hat
Deutschland im Ausland Macht und Ansehen
verloren
die Antwort ist nicht ja sondern ja ja
ja
Gruppenbild in Paris mit deutscher und
französischer Regierung mit Frankreichs
Präsident und Deutschlands Rätsel